we discussed how we should speed up work
on creating the digital single market if
we want to become a truly digital
economy and digital continent we have to
stop the fragmentation of the market we
agreed there are three files we need to
reach agreements on by the end of the
year Chea blocking audio-visual media
service directive and parcel delivery
free flow of data regulation this is an
important priority for the Estonian
presidency the European Council called
on us to finish negotiations on this
file by June 2018 every year we lose
around 400 billion euros to cyberattacks
not to mention the unmeasured costs on
violated privacy
we all agreed that Europe must become
the front-runner for cycles of cyber
security in order to achieve this we
need a holistic approach to the new
cybersecurity package we discussed about
our telecom package about codes and I
would like to say that there is the Ross
rail on the standing that deeper
cooperation in the field of spectrum in
the European Union is definitely needed
gigabit connectivity for main socio
economic drivers I'm talking about
research institutes universities
industries railway stations seaports etc
we have to provide that's kind of our
currency that's kind of connectivity by
2025